[موسيقى]
وهذه اللقطات من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
والاحتجاجات المستمره على تمرير قانون
التقاعد من قبل الرئيس ماكرون دون تصويت
البرلمان
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
خرسون عوده للمشهد بعد حديث روسي عن احباط
محاوله انزال اوكرانيه وعلى وقع احتدام
المعارك في الشرق والجنوب قرار سلوفاكي
بدعم اكياس بمقاتلات تسعه وعشرين وموسكو
تحذر من تصعيد خطير وغير متوقع
ضد بوتين في الاروقه الدوليه امر اعتقال
من الجنائيه الدوليه والكرملين يقول انه
لا قيمه قانونيه له
مشهد الاحتجاجات في فرنسا ضد اقرار قانون
التقاعد يتصاعد واحتجاجات ليليه تتجدد وسط
دعوات لبدء اضراب عام في البلاد وبعد
تجاوز الرئيس الفرنسي قبه البرلمان تحركات
للمعارضه لسحب الثقه من الحكومه ومصادر
تكشف ان الرئيس ماكرون لوح خلال المناقشات
الاخيره لحل البرلمان
في معركه قضائيه مع محاكم البلاد 36 قضيه
تلاحق رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عامر عن خان محكمه لاهورت تقرر منحه حمايه
قضائيه تمنع اعتقاله اسبوعا كاملا وفي
الطريق الى اسلام اباد محكمه العاصمه تصدر
امرا بعدم اعتقاله اثناء قدومه من لاهور
للمثول في قضيه اخرى
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الغضب المتزايد في فرنسا
بسبب قانون التقاعد حيث تجددت المظاهرات
على تصديق الرئيس ايمنويل ماكرون القانون
دون تصويت برلماني فيما اسفرت الاشتباكات
بين الشرطه ومتظاهرين على اعتقال اكثر من
300 شخص
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما المسارات
المحتمله لما بعد الاحتجاجات في فرنسا
20% قالوا انها ستؤدي لخضوع الحكومه
للمطالب بينما 30% راوا انه سيتم حجم
الثقه عن الحكومه بينما قال 50% ان
البرلمان سيحل
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
كشف برنامج الجزيره التحقيقي ما خفي اعظمه
عن وثائق ومراسلات سريه للفريق الروسي
الذي اعتقل في العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس عام
وكشفت تحقيق وفقا للمقابلات والشهادات عن
انخراط الفريق بقياده ماكسيم شوغالي في
اداره عمليه اعاده سيف الاسلام القذافي
للمشهد السياسي الليبي كما وثقت مراسلات
الترتيبات لتجهيز مدارج خاصه في مدن
الليبيه لاستقبال قوات فاجنر الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اسرار الشوكالي هو عنوان تحقيق ما خفي
اعظم الجديد هذه المره من ليبيا توفق هذه
اللقطات الحصريه التي عرضها التحقيق لحظات
الافراج عن الروسي المثير للجدل مكسيم
شوقالي ومساعده من مطار معيتيجا في طرابلس
في ديسمبر 2020 بعد قرابه عام وثمانيه
اشهر من الاعتقال بتهمه التجسس
اعتقال وافراج لفهما كثير من الغموض حتى
اليوم لكن اجهزه شوقالي التي تمت مصادرتها
اثناء عمليه الاعتقال حملت كنزا من
المعلومات والاسرار
في هذا التحقيق حصل ما خفي اعظم على نسخه
من الارشيف السري لشوجالي الذي وثق
مراسلاته السريه مع موسكو وتفاصيل عمل
الفريق الروسي في ليبيا
[موسيقى]
وثقت رسائل شوقالي تفاصيل اجتماعاته
المتكرره مع سيف الاسلام القذافي حيث ادار
شوقالي عمليه اعاده سيف الاسلام للمشهد
السياسي الليبي
[موسيقى]
استطلاعات راي وصفحات اعلاميه موجهه
ولقاءات مع زعماء قبائل كلها هدفت لتهيئه
المناخ لترشيح سيف الاسلام القذافي لاي
انتخابات ليبيه رئاسيه محتمله
تمكنت تحقيق ما خفي اعظم من اجراء مقابله
حصريه مع شوغالي الذي حرص على التاكيد على
انه كان في مهمه بحثيه ولم يخترق القوانين
الليبيه قائلا ان عمليه اعتقاله وجهت من
الخارج وفي كلامه اشاره للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حيث اكد اكثر من متحدث خلال
التحقيق ان مصدر المعلومه التي حددت هويه
ومكان شوقالي كان امريكيا
كشفت الوثائق التي عرضها التحقيق عن جوانب
خفيه مثيره ففي هذه المراسله التي ارسلها
شوقالي لموسكو قال ان سيف الاسلام ابدى
استعداده لتسليم الروس وثائق حس
لاستخدامها ومن بينها مستندات لتلقي
الرئيس الفرنسي الحالي ايمانويل ماكرو
اموالا ليبيه عبر وسطاء عام 2017 وهو
سيحرج ماكرون حسب تعبير سيف الاسلام
[موسيقى]
التعاون بين الفريق الروسي وسيف الاسلام
تمدد للمجال العسكري حيث وثقت هذه
المراسله ابلاغ سيف الاسلام القذافي
الروسي بتجهيز استقبال قواتهم القادمه عبر
السودان في مدارج خاصه في بني وليد وقدامس
وترهون والزنتان كما زود سيف الاسلام
شوقالي بقائمه اسماء قيادات ميدانيه ليبيه
جاهزه للتنسيق في الامر اسرار شوقالي
وفريقه لم تقتصر على الملف الليبي بل كشفت
وثائقه عن صور ومراسلات لادارته حملات
انتخابيه في دول افريقيه بينها مدغشقر عام
وتلك منطقه من مناطق كثيره
ظهر فيها الرجل فهنا وثقت صور عرضها ما
خفي اعظم وجوده في افغانستان بعد الانسحاب
الامريكي منها ومؤخرا وثقت صور حديثه
وجوده ضمن قوات فاجنر التي تقاتل في
اوكرانيا
حيث ورد اسمه مؤخرا على قائمه العقوبات
الاوروبيه للشخصيات الروسيه المرتبطه
بفاجنر
انضموا الينا من طرابلس اسعد الشرتاع
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وهنا في الاستوديو
الدكتور عمر عاشور استاذه الدراسات
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه ابدا معك سيد اسعد
سيد اسعد بدايه ما الذي استوقفكم في هذا
التحقيق
مساء الخير بدايه تحيه لك ولضيفك الكريم
وللمتابعين يعني هناك اعتقد ان التقارير
التقرير تكفل بكل التفاصيل لكن في خطوط
عريضه او استنتاجات سياسيه اولا اهميه
ليبيا بالنسبه لروسيا وحجم هذا التدخل
وتورط الروسي في ليبيا الذي تشعب الى عمل
سياسي مع حفتر وعمل عسكري مع حفتر وعمل
سياسي مع سيف الاسلام
ويؤكد او يؤكد ما نشر في معلومات في هذا
التقرير بان روسيا كانت تعمل لحساب نفسها
وليس لحساب طرف معين في ليبيا وكانت
تستخدم هذه الاطراف المستعده للتواصل
لمصالحها وسؤال يبقى هل ليبيا مهمه في حد
ذاتها بالنسبه لروسيا ام ليبيا بوابه
لافريقيا من جهه اخرى يبين ان هشاشه
المؤسسات السياسيه في ذلك الوقت اثناء
حدوث هذه الواقعه وما بعدها وسوء الت في
هذا الملف وحتى تناخذ تصريحات المسؤولين
الليبيين حول هذا العمل وايضا يعني ما لا
يدعم مجال الشك انا لم يكن باحث عادي يبدو
ان شخص عسكري وكذلك عالم ملم كان يعمل
بدور العين والعقل قبل دخول القوه الى
الارض يبدو انه كان
يرجح القرارات التي تخدم روسيا سواء على
المستوى العسكري او على المستوى السياسي
ويحمل صفه مدنيه حتى لا تظهر اصابع او
بصمات روسيا بشكل مباشر في المحافل
الدوليه للادانه وحتى يترك له مخرج اذا ما
تم القبض عليه اشرت الى اكثر من نقطه ولكن
تحول اليك دكتور عمر دكتور عمر اشار السيد
اسعد الى الدور الروسيه في ليبيا ما اهميه
ما كشفه هذا التحقيق فيما يتعلق خاصه ان
فاجنر اليوم في دور كبير تلعبه داخل
اوكرانيا
اولا تغنينا على هذا التقرير او تحقيق
الرائع حقيقه مفصل وعميق للغايه وبكثير من
التفاصيل الهامه التي تكشف لاول مره الجزء
المتعلق بفاقنا الان مستوى اخر في
اوكرانيا يعني نحن نتكلم عن قوه مقدرتها
الجنين حكومه الطوائم الوفاه الوطني في
ليبيا بين 600 800 فرد هذه قوات كتيبه لكن
كانت فرصه بمعنى انه كانت اضافت قوه هائله
للقوات التي تتحدى الجيش الوطني الليبي
وحلفائه التي تتحدى الحكومه المركزيه
كمدخل لما يجري في اوكرانيا ولكن ماذا
الجانب الليبي ودور فاجنر هناك كان هام
الغايه لكن اريد ان نضع الامور في حجمها
الحقيقي لانه
يعني الذي عرضتموه هو صوره حرب هجينه يعني
تقريبا مكرره مما حدث في القرن ان يجد
سياسي منبوذ ربما فشل لديه مجموعه من
التواصلات على الارض يسلحوا ويدربه وهذا
السياسي يرسم له خريطه الداخليه لمن معه
من القاده العسكريين من يستطيع شرائه يرسم
له من المجتمع المدني الذي يمكن استمالته
في مقابل خدماته هذا في الحاله حاله القرم
ما حدث بالضبط في فبراير 2014 مارس 2015
فالاطار المقارنه واضح هنا الفارق الوحيد
هي ان القلم كالنجاح استراتيجي لروسيا
ليبيا كان فشل استراتيجيه لاننا لم تحقق
هدف في النهايه القرام تحولت كجزء منها
ونجحت بسبب 20 الف جندي روسي كانوا
متواجدين
في القيم لان هذه العضلات التي امنت عمليه
النجاح او عمليه الاختراق الاستراتيجي
الذي حدث وبعد ذلك الانزال الجوي والبحري
الذي حدثه هناك في حاله فاجنر في ليبيا لم
يكن هناك هذا النجاح لان القوه كانت قوه
بسيطه صحيح اختراق هجين هائل صحيح اداء
متميز في عين زرف جنوب طرابلس قنص متميز
اداء مدفعي دقيق للغايه
اختراقات استخباريه متعدده حدثت تحالف مع
السياسيين كما شاهدنا مع بعض السياسيين
ولديهم قدرات فكان هناك يعني نقل مستوى
تكتيكي يوجد بعض النجاح مستوى استراتيجي
لم تتغير لا توجد هناك حكومه الان في
طرابلس مواليا لروسيا ولا توجد سيطره
كامله فيجب ان نضع الامور في حجمها
النجاحان كانوا في سوريا تثبيت النظام وفي
القرم الاستيلاء عليها الفاشل كان في
ليبيا فشل على مستوى الاستراتيجي
روسيه في ليبيا اعود مره جديده الى السيد
اسعد سيد اسعد يعني دعمت روسيا وفقا لهذا
التحقيق سيف الاسلام القذافي هل هذا الدعم
لا يزال
مستمرا ولماذا سيف الاسلام القذافي
بتقديرك
يعني
القذافي لان لخلفيته طبعا وفي النظام
السابق وهنا لديه عدد من الانصار والذين
يدينون له بالولاء ولعائلته بالتالي هناك
شخصيه جاهزه يعني في نظر الروس يمكن
الاستثمار فيها
اعتقد ان الاستثمار في سيف لا يزال موجود
لكن التعثر في توظيف سيف على الوجه الامثل
ان سيف كشخصيه لم يكن مؤهل يعني حقيقه مثل
ما جاء في مراسلات
مراسلات فيغالي وبالتالي شخصيه صيف التي
تبدو مهزوزه وغير بعيد عن الواقع كما
وصفها مكسيم في تقاريره هذا اعتقد الذي
عرقل ايضا من ناحيه اخرى ان مشروع الروسي
اصطدم بعوامل خارجيه لم تكن محسوبه لدى
الروس اعتقد ان
فيغالي قام بدوره على الوجه الامثل وقدم
صوره حتى على الانتخابات البلديه
والشخصيات السياسيه والقاده الموالين
والواقع الاجتماعي لكن كل ذلك في حساب
العوامل الليبيه المحليه صرفه ما افشل هذه
العمليه الكبيره الحقيقه والدقيقه للغايه
الاستخباراتيا وسياسيا وعسكريا على الارض
ما افشله هو الوجود عامل دولي كان مفاجئ
وهو الاستعانه
بالمساعده التركيه الذي احبط هذه العمليه
ولو لم يكن ذلك لربما كنا نشاهد الان
واقعا اخر ولا اعتقد ان كل هذا الاستثمار
الروسي الكبير سوف تتخلى عنه روسيا بسهوله
لولا انشغالها ايضا عامل دولي لم يكن
متوقع وهو الحرب الاوكرانيه وتورطها الى
هذا المدى وهذه الخسائر التي حدثت واهميه
اوكرانيا الى سيد عمر هل اهتمام روسيا
اليوم باوكرانيا والحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا ادت الى تراجع دورها في مناطق
اخرى حسب التحقيق
لروسيا ادوار متعدده في مناطق مختلفه منها
افريقيا على سبيل المثال نعم الاجابه
البسيطه نعم هي سحبت العديد من عناصر
فاجنر من افريقيا ومن ليبيا وليس سرا انهم
ذهبوا الى اوكرانيا في في فبراير ومارس
العام الماضي ثم تضاعفت هذه الاعداد الان
نحن نتكلم في تقديرات ما بين 40,050 الف
اغلبيتهم من المدنيين بحق عام والذين يعني
زادوا من اعداد هذه الشركه من ناحيه
فالتركيز الاولي على اوكرانيا لكن ليبيا
ما زالت مهمه ليبيا دوله هامه لها موقع
جيوسجي هام دوله غنيه نفطيه ويوجد تواجد
ويوجد حلفاء ويوجد سياسيين يتطلعون لان
ياتي لهم دعم خارجي سياسي ومالي واستخباري
وربما عسكري وامني يساعدهم الوصول الى
السلطه في ليبيا متاحه في وقت لاحق لكن
الان الاولويه الاولى هي اوكرانيا وهذه
حرب رئيس بوتين يعني لو خاسرها يعني سيكون
هناك تداعيات سياسيه داخليه على على ليبيا
على سوريا على روسيا وعلى فاجنر تحديدا
سواء في ليبيا او في خارج ليبيا شكرا لك
دكتور عمر عاشور استاذ الدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه كنت معنا هنا في الاستوديو
وشكر موصول للسيده اسعد الشرتاع الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي من طرابلس
[موسيقى]
الى مشهد الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث يتواصل
ودعم حلفاء اكياف لها لمواجهه القوات
الروسيه اخر قرارات الدعم جاءت من
سلوفاكيا التي اعلنت موافقتها على ارسال
ثلاثه عشره مقاتله من طراز منك 29 الى
اوكرانيا يذكر ان الحكومه البولنديه اعلنت
امس نيتها تسريع عمليه تسليم اوكرانيا
اربع طائرات حربيه على الاقل من الطراز
نفسه
وبعد قرار الدعم السلوفاكي قال الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي ميرسي لينسكي ان هذا
الدعم لبلاده يشمل حزمه قويه من الاسلحه
الجويه والمضاده للطائرات بما في ذلك نقل
طائره ميغا 29 مضيفا بان اتفاقيات بروكسل
نجحت
هذا التطور علقت عليها موسكو محذره حيث
قال الكريم ان قرار بولندا وسلوفاكيا
تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات ميجا 29 مثال على
زياده عدد من دول الناتو مشاركتها في
الصراع واستبعد الكريم تاثير توليد هذه
الطائرات على نتيجه المعارك لافتا الى ان
المعدات التي توفرها وارسو لكياف ستدمر
لكن على ايه حال هناك اسئله عديده بشان
الدعم اللوجستيه في اوكرانيا وقدره جيشها
على استخدام هذه المقاتلات
طائره سوفيتيه الصنع في طريقها الى ميدان
المعارك في اوكرانيا ستكون في يد القوات
الاوكرانيه للروسيه للمره الاولى تتسلم
طائرات النفاثه منذ بدايه الحرب تقدم
الجارتان سلوفاكيا وبولندا حزمه اولى من
هذه المقاتلات التي تمتلكها قائد سلاح
الجو الاوكراني يرحب بالميك وعينه على
الاف سته عشر الامريكيه يقول المسؤول
الاوكراني ان ميغ تسعه وعشرين لن تحل
المشكله لكنها ستسهم في تعزيز القدرات
الاوكرانيه تتمنع واشنطن حتى الان عن
تلبيه الرغبات الاوكرانيه يقول المتحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي ان قرار
بولندا لا يغير الحسابات الامريكيه فيما
يتعلق بطائرات اف 16 تقلل روسيا من اهميه
هذا الدعم يقول ناطق باسم ان الامر اشبه
بمحاولات اتلاف المعدات القديمه غير
الضروريه في بولندا
ويجدد المسؤول الروسيه التهديد بان
المساعدات الغربيه لاوكرانيا ستتعرض
للتدمير تمت اسئله عن البنيه التحتيه
والتشغيل والتدريب لهذه الطائرات دمرت
القوات الروسيه منذ الاسابيع الاولى للحرب
90 في المئه من المطارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه هذا يعني ان حركه هذه الطائرات
ستكون صعبه الا اذا تمكن الاوكرانيون من
اعاده تاهيل هذه المطارات او حمايه ما
تبقى منها في مناطق لا تصل اليها الضربات
الروسيه هذا الامر لا يبدو سهل القوه
الروسيه تسيطر بشكل كامل على الاجواء
الاوكرانيه من ناحيه ايجابيه بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين فان الطيارين ليسوا بحاجه
للتدريب على هذه الطائرات فاوكرانيا
الدوله السابقه في الاتحاد السوفيتي
خبرتها طويله في استخدام الاسلحه
السوفييتيه كانت تمتلك تسعه وعشرين قبل ان
تدمرها روسيا في الحرب هذا يسهل على
الجنود الاوكرانيين استخدام هذه بفاعليه
عاليه مقارنه بالحاجه للتدريب على طائره
اف 16 الامريكيه في الجغرافيا تجد ميغ
تسعه وعشرون مكانها في الخطوط الاماميه
للجبهه يتوقع خبراء ان تؤدي دورا في سد
فجوه في الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني بالاضافه
الى استهداف القوات الروسيه في المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها باقليم دومباس والمناطق
الجنوبيه الاهم هو ان هذه الميغ في يد
البولنديين تطورت ليضاف اليها صواريخ هارم
الامريكيه وهي صواريخ مضاده للرادارات
تعمل بكفاءه ضد المواقع الروسيه على الارض
الاوكرانيه هكذا تبدو امدادات بولندا
وسلوفاكيا اضافه نوعيه لصالح اوكرانيا
لكنها في الوقت نفسه تفتح الباب امام
الاسئله اللوجستيه وامد هذه الحرب في
عامها الثاني
انضموا الينا من عمان اللواء فايز طويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز
قائد سلاح الجو الاوكرانيه يقول ان هذه
الطائرات لن تحل المشكله اذا ما الذي
ستقدمه
لا يعني هي لن تحل المشكله بصوره جذريه
ولكنها تقدم اضافه لا يمكن تجاهلها عندما
نتحدث عن 13 طائره من سلوفاكيا واربع
طائرات من بولندا نتحدث عن 17 طائره نتحدث
عن رقم كبير التقرير جاء على عمليات
الخدمه اللوجستيه الطائرات الاوكرانيه لا
تزال تشترك وفي معظم الايام هناك طلعات
للطائرات الاوكرانيه الفرق الرئيسي انه 29
تم تصنيع العديد من الاجيال يعني الطائره
التي قدمت الى سلوفاكيا ليست مطابقه لما
قدم لبولندا لرومانيا لبلغاريا لاوكرانيا
او حتى للجيش السوفيتي نزع منها بعض
الامور ولكن هذه الطائره هولندا الاسلحه
التي تقدمها او الطائرات التي تقدمها تحمل
صواريخ هارم ماذا يعني ذلك
في سياق المعارك بالطبع هذا ما كنت اود
العشاء هذا ما كنت اود الاشاره له انه هذه
الطائره
سلوفاكيه هي من طراز يو بي اس وهذا الطراز
تم اجراء تعديلات عليه انا اتحدث عن
الطائرات التي تقدم من سلوفاكيا تم اجراء
تعديلات تتعلق في الكمبيوترات اصبح بها
اربع كمبيوترات بدل الكمبيوترات القديمه
مدى الرادار مئه كيلو متر الى الامام 45
كيلو متر الى الخلف وكذلك الطائرات التي
زودت على بولندا تم تزويدها بتسليح غربي
بين مسلوفاكيا لا بقيت على السلاح الروسي
بدون رغم كل ذلك رغم كل ذلك ورغم التحفظات
والحديث عنها بانها لا تقدم الكثير وستدمر
الايام ستثبت انها ستحدث نوع من الفرق
لماذا لانها تعتبر طائره تفوق جوي او
طائره الصف الامامي وعندما تصنيعها صنعت
لمواجهه الاف 16 طيب ابقى معنا فايز على
المستوى الميداني عاد الحديث عن خرسون
جنوبا الى مشهد المعارك المحتدمه الحديث
كان من الطرف الروسي حيث قال حاكم
المقاطعه الموالي لموسكو انه اتم احباطه
عمليه انزال للقوات الاوكرانيه على الضفه
اليسرى لنهر واضاف ان نيران المدفعيه
الروسيه اغرقت بارجه اوكرانيه على متنها
كتيبه انزال كانت تحاول العبور في منطقه
السد كخوفك الى الضفه اليسرى من نهر وان
عشرات القتل الاوكرانيين سقطوا خلال هذه
العمليه واشار الى ان ما وقع يعد اكبر
محاوله عبور اوكرانيه للنهر خلال الفتره
الماضيه
الحديث عن خرسون يتضمن مع مشهد القتال
المستمر للسيطره على باخموت حيث اكدت هيئه
اركان الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
تواصل محاولاتها للتقدم نحو مدينه باخموت
رغم الخسائر التي تتكبدها كما اكدت ان
القوات الروسيه شنت هجمات وصفتها بالفاشله
على مناطق عده جنوب دانياسك وفي مقاطعه
خاركيف محاوله اختراق خطوط الدفاع
في المقابل قال موقع ريبار العسكري
الروسيه ان قوات فاجنر تواصل الضغط على
القوات الاوكرانيه في باخمت من الجهتين
الشماليه والجنوبيه في مسعد لتطويقها من
كل الاتجاهات واضاف الموقع ان قتالا عنيفا
يدور في بعض الاحياء وسط وشمال المدينه
مره جديده اليك لواء فايز للتعليق على
عوده خرسون الى تصدر المشهد من جديد
بتقديرك ما هي الاسباب
يعني انا اعتبره تصدر جزئي لماذا الحديث
عن محاوله بارجه انزال كتيبه الى الضفه
اليسرى من نار خرسون قد يكون لي تحافظ على
استخدام كلمه بارجه لان البارجه اصلا هي
ليست سفينه ابرار وهي ليست معده لانزال
قوات هي وسير هي هي تعتبر
البارجه اكبر من المدمره تستخدم القوه
الناريه هي
سفينه قتال وليس ابرار ولكن انسجاما مع ما
تم الاعلان عنه لا اعتقد ان البرج تستطيع
حمل كتيبه انما وبالتالي يصبح كلمه كتيبه
مفهوم مطاط مفهوم مفتوح هي حمله جنود اذا
دعيني اقول هي قد تكون محاوله جر انتباه
وتشتيت التركيز الروسي عن بالنسبه لباخمت
واجبارهم على تخفيض الضغط على ونقل جزء من
القوات الى خرسن لمواجهه تداعيات
اعتبرت مقدمتها هذه البارجه وعمليه
الانزيم محاوله الانجاب المهمه او الهدف
لم تنجح اوكرانيا في ذلك وفقا للجانب
الروسي كيف يمكن ان يؤثر ذلك على المعارك
في بخمه
لهذا السبع ما انا قلت لك انه اتحفظ على
كلمه بارجه وعمليه الانسان لانها ليست
معده انزال لو كان هناك انزال حقيقي سيكون
مختلف هناك المعديات وهناك قطع بحريه
مخصصه لهذا الشيء وهناك لازم ان يجب ان
تكون نقاط عبور متعدده مما يوشي بحمله
عبور للنهر اذا هي عمليه لفت انتباه ليس
اكثر وبالتالي قد تنجح هذا النوع من
الخداع الاستراتيجي
حتى الان لا اقول انها نجحت هذا يعتمد على
رد الفعل الروسي لانه يجب ان ياخذ هذه
المحاوله بعين الاعتبار هل سيقوم بسحب جزء
من قواته من ام سيقوم باحضار قوات من
مناطق اخرى من ماريوبول او ميلتوبل او
غيرها وبالتالي انما تعتبر حدث جديد يلفت
الانتباه ويجب معالجته
فايز الدويريه الخبير العسكريه
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان
على وقع الحرب والمعارك تتواصل المحاولات
الدوليه للضغط على روسيا حيث اصدرت
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكرتي توقيف في
حق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ومفوضه
حقوق الطفل في الرئاسه ماريا بلوفا وقال
رئيس المحكمه بيوتر
ان المذكرتين اسطرت لمسؤوليتهما في
الترحيل غير القانوني للاطفال في اوكرانيا
اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكرتي
اعتقال مرتبطتين بالاوضاع في اوكرانيا بحق
السيد فلاديمير بوتين رئيس الاتحاد الروسي
وماريا بلوفا مفوضه الرئيس الروسي لحقوق
الاطفال بتهم ارتكاب الجرائم حرب مزعومه
تتمثل في ترحيل الاطفال من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحتله الى الاتحاد الروسي
يحضر القانون الدولي على القوه المحتله
نقل المدنيين من الاراضي التي يعيشون فيها
الى مناطق اخرى يتمتع الاطفال بحمايه خاصه
بموجب اتفاقيه جنيف محتويات المذكرتين
السريه من اجل حمايه الضحايا وتولي
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اهميه كبيره
لحمايه الضحايا وخاصه الاطفال ومع ذلك قرر
القضاه الذين يتعاملون مع هذه القضيه
اعلان وجود المذكرتين لصالح العداله
منع ارتكاب جرائم في المستقبل
وفي اول رد فعل من موسكو على قرار المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه قالت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيات الروسيه ماريا زخروفه ان قرار
اصدار مذكره باعتقال الرئيس بوتين لا
اهميه له على الاطلاق واضافت زخرفه ان
روسيا ليست عضوا في نظام روما الاساسي
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ولا مسؤوليات
لديها تجاه المحكمه
وقبيل قمه مرتقبه في موسكو بين الرئيسين
الصيني والروسي قالت موسكو ان المحادثات
ستشمل امدادات الاسلحه والنزاع في
اوكرانيا وابدت كياف انفتاحها على دور
صيني بشرط احترام وحده اراضها وبينما قالت
اداره الرئيس بايدن انها ستعمل على ترتيب
اتصال بين الرئيس الصيني ونظيره الاوكراني
حذر البنتاجون من اي دعم عسكري لروسيا
في اول زياره خارجيه له بعد اعاده انتخابه
رئيسا للبلاد لولايه ثالثه يتوجه الرئيس
الصيني الى موسكو للقاء الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الزياره التي يتوقع ان
تثير كثيرا من الترقب في العواصم الغربيه
ستركز بحسب مصادر رسميه صينيه وروسيه على
التعاون العسكري والتقني والاقتصادي
وقضايا الطاقه اضافه بالطبع الى ملف الحرب
في اوكرانيا لاسيما وان القمه المنتظره
تاتي بعد اقل من شهر على تقديم بيجين
مبادره لحل الازمه هناك وفي حين اكد مساعد
الرئيس الروسي ان بلاده تثمن عاليا ما
وصفه بالموقف المتوازن للقياده الصينيه من
النزاع في اوكرانيا وبانه يتوافق الى حد
كبير والرؤيه الروسيه فان ذلك لم يحل دون
اعلان كييف انفتاحها على دور صيني اذ اعلن
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمت
مع نظيره الصيني تشينجان المبادئ التي
يمكن على اساسها استعاده السلام في
اوكرانيا مع التجديد على مبدا وحده اراضي
البلاد ورغم ان الحلفاء الغربيين لكييف
وفي مقدمتهم الولايات المتحده سبق ان
شككوا بالمبادره الصينيه على اعتبار ان
بيجين ومهما حاولت ان تلعب دورا محايدا
ستبقى اقرب لروسيا من اوكرانيا فان ذلك لم
يحل دون تشجيع خجول من البيت الابيض للصين
لكي تنفتح اكثر على وجهه النظر للاوكرانيه
اذ نقلت شبكه السي ان ان عن مسؤولين
امريكيين عزمهم على ترتيب اتصال بين رئيس
الصيني ونظيره الاوكراني وايا يكن رهان
الامريكي على هذه الخطوه ومدى قدرتها على
احداث تغيير جوهري بموقف بيجين من كييف
فان القلق الاكبر لديها يبقى دائما من
تقديم الصين لاي دعم عسك لروسيا اذ اكد
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
العلاقات بين بيجين وموسكو تعمقت بشكل
كبير منذ اندلاع الحرب وان كانت لا توجد
ادله حتى الان على استخدام اسلحه صينيه في
ساحه المعارك وكانت الخارجيه الصينيه قد
اكدت ان بيجين طالما تبنت موقفا مسؤولا
تجاه تصدير المعدات العسكريه وان شددت على
ان التعاون الصيني الروسي يتمتع بامكانيات
هائله ومرونه قويه وان البلدين قدما
نموذجا جديدا للعلاقات الدوليه
تنضم الينا
مديره مركز روسيا اوروبا واسيا للدراسات
سيده تيريزا مع زياره الرئيس الصيني الى
روسيا عاد الحديث عن خطه السلام الصينيه
هل الظروف العسكريه والسياسيه باتت مهيئه
لنجاح اي وساطه
اعتقد ان الكل يتمنى ان يشاهدوا تحقيق
السلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا
وهي حرب طبعا
شنتها روسيا ولكن رغم ذلك لفت جميع يودون
اعطاء فرصه للسلام ولكن اعتقد اليوم ومع
قرار المحكمه الجنائيات الدوليه وقراره
الذي اصدرته حول اعتقاله بوتين بسبب
ارساله اطفال من اوكرانيا الى روسيا هذا
فيه بعض التاثيرات السيئه على الصين ورئيس
سهال التوقيت لزيارته لموسكو ونتذكر انه
في عام 2022 بعد ايام فقط من غزوه
اوكرانيا شاهدنا ان الرئيس الصيني وفتن
علنا ان علاقتهم بلا اي حدود وبالتالي
سيكون الصعب بالنسبه للناس ان يصدقوا بان
السائل الرئيس شي او يمكن ان يكون وسيط
حيادي في هذه الازمه واعتقد انك خطر
بالنسبه
لان الرئيس الصيني قد يقبل ام من الرئيس
الروسي وهذا ايضا
لانه ونجد ان كثير من وطبعا الصين لديها
مشكلتها في الاطفال اذا انا قد ارسلوا
الكثير من الاطفال المناطق فيها مشاكل
ونقلوهم الى اخرى وبالتالي هناك خطا من
الرئيس الصيني قد تقل قدرته ان يقوم بدور
اللاعب الحيادي وايضا قد هو تلحق به
سلبيه مقام به بوتن في اوكرانيا الى تشكيك
بحياديه الصين او دورها والى ان الرئيس
الصيني يمكن ان يخضع لاملاءات الرئيس
الروسي اذا كان الامر كذلك لماذا تسعى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لترتيب اتصال
بين زيلنسكي والرئيس الصيني بحسب سي ان ان
اعتقد ان هذا امر ايجابي لانه في عام 2013
سجن بينج وقع على وثيقه تضمن السلامه
والسياده اوكرانيا وكان ذلك في عمليه
العمليه قد فاتتهم
وينبغي
وينغي الصين ان تدعم سياده اوكرانيا لكن
بقيه صامته خلال سنه كامله للحرب وقف فقط
في الذكرى الاولى للحرب اصدروا
اثناء بيانا من 12 نقطه
لحل هذه الازمه مستخدمين اللغه التي
تستخدمها روسيا ولم يقول انها حرب عمليه
خاصه وبالتالي كما قلت سابقا الجميع
يتمنون ان يشاهدوا تحقيق السلام في
المنطقه لكن ليس على حساب ان روسيا تستطيع
ان تتمتع بوقف اطلاق النار
وتستريحها وتعيد التسريح نفسها وموقعها
وبالتالي لابد
النقاشات
يحاول عده مرات خلال السنه الاولى من
الحرب ان يمد يده الى رئيس الصيني
لضمان سياده بلاده ولكن لم يقولوا شيئا
ولما الان حقيقه ان هو يقدر ياخذ شماعًا
افتراضيا او يعتبر نصرا واختراقا وعلينا
انتظر النتيجه اعتقد انها يحاول ان يحسن
سمعته على الصعيدين المحلي والدولي
ولنامل بانه ستنقي صاحب التطورات الملموسه
تحصل لكن اليوم في الناحيه السياسيه في
ذكر بان ان هناك ادله ان الصين كانت تبيعه
منذ بنادق ام سته عشر
لروسيا وبالتالي هذا يعني انهم يبعثون
اسلحه
فتاكه الى روسيا وبالتالي لا يمكن يكون
لاعبين محايدين ويظن يبيع ون
عجلات مدرعه تساعد روسيا في حربها في
اوكرانيا اضافه انه من الواضح انه انه
واحده من اكبر اللاعبين عن الطاقه الروسيه
ويحصلون على الطاقه الروسيه باسعار
المخفضه شكرا لك فعلا مديره مركز روسيا
اوروبا واسيا للدراسات من بروكسل
في المشهد التصاعدي بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده مازال الحديث مستمرا بشان تحطم
المسيره الامريكيه فوق البحر الاسود وسط
تاكيد واشنطن نيتها مواصله التحليق في كل
الاماكن فيما تحذر موسكو من التداعيات
نقاط التماس الجويه بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا هو ما سنناقشه بعد قليل في فقره في
المتابعه
[موسيقى]
كنا نتحدثنا في بدايه الحصاد عن
الاحتجاجات المستمره في فرنسا تمديدا
باقرار تعديد القانون التقاعد ويواصل الاف
الفرنسيين في مدن عده الاحتجاج بعد اقرار
الرئيس الفرنسي
القانون دون تمريره في البرلمان وقد اعلنت
الداخليه الفرنسيه اعتقال 310 اشخاص هذه
المشاهد نشاهدها الان من باريس حيث تشهد
مواجهات بين الشرطه
والمحتجين فيما تتواصل اذا التظاهرات على
رفع سن التقاعد
مباشره من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس حيث
تستمر الاحتجاجات على رفع سن التقاعد
النقابات العماليه ترفض هذا القانون فيما
تتمسك فيه الحكومه وكانت الحكومه قد لجات
الى مجلس الشيوخ لاقراره بعيدا عن مجلس
النواب فيما لوحت احزاب المعارضه بسحب
الثقه من الحكومه
اذا هذا وتسعى احزاب المعارضه الفرنسيه
الى حجم الثقه عن الحكومه في وقت لوحه
فيها الرئيس ماكرون باحتمال حل البرلمان
نحو ازمه سياسيه واجتماعيه يدفع مشروع
تعديل انظمه التقاعد الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
فاصرار ماكرون على تمريره بكل الوسائل حتى
بدون اغلبيه في مجلسي البرلمان يقابله
عناد الشارع واحزاب المعارضه على رفضه
ومن بين الاثمان التي يبدو ان الرئيس
الفرنسي مستعد لدفعها في سعيه الحديث
لتمرير القانون التضحيه بحكومه التي تواجه
محاوله حجم ثقه من احزاب المعارضه
اخر الاحزاب المطالبه براس الحكومه كتله
النواب المستقلين بالاضافه الى كتله
التجمع الوطني ويحتاج هؤلاء الى جمع 287
صوتا في البرلمان من اجل اسقاط الحكومه في
جلسه تصويت ستجرى الاثنين وفي حال نجاح
المعارضه في اقناع 30 نائبا من اليمين
المحافظ فستصبح مهمتهم في اسقاط الحكومه
ممكنه وسيفتح هذا الباب امام سيناريوهات
اخرى اما بتشكيل الرئيس حكومه جديده او حل
البرلمان والدعوه الى انتخابات البرلمانيه
في غضون 20 الى 40 يوما سيصعب التكهن في
المناخ الحالي ما ان كانت نتائجها ستكون
لصالح الرئيس وحزبه
من ارتفاع التضخم وتدني الخدمات
الاجتماعيه في دوله اعتادت النقابات فيها
على انتزاع مكاسب عبر التظاهر والاحتجاج
ينضم الينا من
باريسيه في جامعه باريس ثمانيه سيد ايف
ما هي السنيوهات المحتمله ما الذي ستواجهه
فرنسا في المرحله المقبله للاحتجاجات
مستمره وهي احتجاجات ليليه ونجد مواجهات
مع الشرطه ايضا مستمره
اول سيناريو هو ان المعارضه السياسيه في
البرلمان تصوت الموافقه على
سحب الثقه من الحكومه وبعد ذلك تجري
انتخابات هذا امر محتمل جدا لان اليمين
المتطرف واليسار
الذي يسوطان سويه ذلك الاحتمال عفوا ضعيف
وليس قوي
وبالتاليات تكون كبيره جدا وتستمر لفتره
طويله بحيث ان الحكومه تفطر بعد فتره من
الزمن بان لا تطبق هذا القانون الذي
اصدرته
سيد ايف من الواضح باننا فقدنا الاتصال مع
السيد ايفا سانتومي استاذ العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه باريس عاد معنا من جديد حسب ما
يبدو
لان هذا خلق مناخه من الاحتجاجات الشديده
وبحيث انه في نهايه مثل سنه مثلا سواء
كانت
اليمين المتطرف او اليسار قد يصل الى
السلطه في انتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه طيب
انقطع الصوت قليلا سيد تحدثت عند احتجاجات
وتحدثت ايضا عن تصويت المعارضه لسحب الثقه
واعتبرته احتمالا ضعيفا ماذا عن امكانيه
ان يقوم الرئيس بحل البرلمان هل هذا
الاحتمال وارد وما هي مخاطره حتى على
الرئيس نفسه ماكرون
من الاحتمال ضعيف جدا ان يتولى يقوم
الرئيس بمبادره حلل البرلمان لكنه قد
يفترض ذلك اذا ما احد طلبي سحب الثقه حصل
على الغالبيه في الجمعيه الوطنيه وبالتالي
الاحتمال لكن لحد الان واليوم ضعيف جدا
شكرا لك
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه باريس
ثمانيه كنت معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
في معركه مستمره داخل اروقه المحاكم يواجه
رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه السابقه عمران
خان العشرات من القضايا المختلفه خلال
اليوم مثوله خان امام محكمه لاهور التي
منحته حمايه قضائيه لمده اسبوع تحول تحول
دون اعتقاله بطلب من محاميه وكانت محكمه
اسلام اباد اصدرت امرا بعدم اعتقال خان
اثناء تنقلهم لاهور الى العاصمه للمتولي
غدا امامها في قضيه اخرى
يحاول الرئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان جاهدا تجاوز الكثير من
التعقيدات القانونيه التي تحيط به على
خلفيات قضايا عديده
هنا في المحكمه العليا في لاهول نجح خان
ومحامه في الحصول على حمايه قضائيه لمده
اسبوع تحول دون اعتقاله بناء على تسعه
محاضر مفتوح ضده عندما ينتقل السب الى
العاصمه اسلام اباد ومن المقرر ان يمثل
خان هناك امام محكمه الابتدائيه للنظر في
قضيه تتعلق باساءته التصرف في عدد من
الهدايا باهضه الثمن كان قد تلقاها من
رؤساء الدول اثناء فتره حكمه وكانت محكمه
اسلام اباد العليا قد منعت الشرطه من
اعتقال خان اثناء انتقاله من لاهور لاسلام
اباد لكن فريق الدفاع عنه اصر على ان يحصل
خان على تلك الحمايه من محكمه لاهور ايضا
تفاديا لامكانيه اعتقاله في لاهور
تعددت الاتهامات والشكاوى ضد خان منذ حجم
الثقه عن حكومته في العاشر من ابريل
الماضي
فهو يواجه 36 قضيه تنظر فيها عدد من
المحاكم الباكستانيه تلك القضايا تتنوع
بين محاوله القتل العمد وممارسه الارهاب
والتحريض على العنف وسوء استخدام السلطه
واهانه القضاء والتلاعب الضريبي
وحسب تصريحات خان للجزيره فان تلك القضايا
هي جزء من خمس وثمانين شكوى فتحت ضده وقد
رفض القضاء معظمها لانها لا ترقى لمستوى
قضيه
وطالما نفع عمران خان وانصاره تلك التهم
والشكاوى ويقولون ان حكومه شهباز شريف
الراهنه المؤلفه من عده احزاب معارضه
لحركه انصاف التي يتزعمها تسعى بشتى الطرق
للتضييق عليه والتقليل من شعبيته وبينها
تلك الدعاء والقضائيه ومنذ الاطاحه به
يمارس عمران خان ضغوطا على حك ومه خلفه
شهبا الشريف من خلال تكثيف التجمعات
الكبرى لمؤيديه في مختلف المواقع كما حل
مجلسي اقليم البنجاب وسط البلاد وخير
البخت نخوه الشمالي الغربي اللذين يسيطر
عليهما حزبه في اطار الضغط لاجراء
انتخابات عامه مبكره
[موسيقى]
نعود الى ملف الاتهامات المتعلقه بتحطم
المسيره الامريكيه في اجواء البحر الاسود
قبل ايام حيث فتحت هذه الاتهامات باب
الجدل مجددا بشان مناطق التماس المحتمله
في الجو بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا اولى
هذه المناطق واهمها هي البحر الاسود حيث
تشكل قواعد الاشتباك هناك نقطه اشكاليه
بعد ضم روسيا شبه جزيره القرم ما جعل
الحدود الروسيه هناك مختلفا عليها بحر
البلطيق ايضا هو نقطه ساخنه لاصطدام
المحتمل طلعات كثيره تجري لمقاتلات تابعه
للناتو واخرى امريكيه وهي منطقه غير بعيده
عن حدود روسيا اذا كما نشاهد هنا بحر
البلطيق نقطه ساخنه ايضا ايضا هناك اجواء
بحر باريس او البحر الابيض المتوسط شمال
غرب روسيا وشمال النرويج وهي منطقه غير
بعيده بالحقيقه عن بحر البلطيق وفي مقطع
اخر من خريطه العالم تبدو حدود الولايات
المتحده وروسيا متقاربه جدا اين في مضيق
بارينج شمال شرق روسيا المواجه لولايه
الاسكا الامريكيه وهو كذلك من مناطق
التماس
المحتمله وهنا قرب الحدود مع اليابان يقع
اقليم بريموري اقصى الشرق الروسي في منطقه
المحيط
الهادئ وهي كذلك منطقه تماس محتمله
هذا التماس يعيد للاذهان معاهده الاجواء
المفتوحه متى ولدت والانسحابات التي
شهدتها اقرت هذه المعاهده عام
1992 في هلسنكي من قبل 27 دوله ودخلت حيز
التنفيذ مطلع عام 2002 وهي تضم حاليا
32 دوله
قد اعلنت انسحابها من المعاهده في نوفمبر
2020 خلال اداره الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب فيما اعلنت موسكو عن انسحابها رسميا
من المعاهده اعتبارا من الثامن عشر من
ديسمبر 2021 ردا على الانسحاب الامريكي
المعاهده تتيح للدول الاعضاء استخدام
طائرات استطلاعا مزوده باجهزه لراستي جميع
انواع الاسلحه الموجوده في الدول الاخرى
اثناء تنفيذ مهماتها كما تحصل طائرات
الدول الاخرى على المعلومات التي يتم
جمعها ايضا تسمح هذه المعاهده وفق بنودها
لجيش بلد عضو فيها بتنفيذ عدد محدد من
الرحلات الاستطلاعيه فوق بلد عضو اخر بشرط
ابلاغه بالامر قبل وقت قصير حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من جناب جاممارك ريكلي
رئيس قسم المخاطر العالميه في مركز جنيف
لسياسات الامن اهلا بك
فعليا بعد الذي جرى فوق البحر الاسود
وسقوط الطائره الامريكيه درون الامريكيه
هل تم تطويق هذا الحادث ام نقاط التماس
كما ذكرناها سابقا هي ممكن ان تؤدي الى
حوادث مماثله ربما اخطر
ان هذه الحوادث
ليست بامر الذي لا سابقه له
وفي مارس السنه الماضيه وروسيا
خطوط منع التي مواجهه واعتمال التماس
والفكره فراى ذلك هو انه عندما تحصل اي
حادث
فبدلا من
تلك الوضع
يتطور ويتصاعد فان الجانبين من العسكريين
طبعا تبادل الحديث ومحاوله شرح ما حصل
واسوابه ما هو مهم في هذه الحاله هو انها
المسيره اسقطت بعد فوق الاجواء الدوليه
وبالتالي يمكن الطيران فوقها واليوم سمعنا
الولايات المتحده انه كانت محاوله
لرمي الوقود الطائره الروسيه على هذه
المسيره
ومحاول ذلك لتخويف وابعاده
الطائره او المسيره الامريكيه
الموجوده وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان
ذكرت بان هذا الحادث ليس فريدا من عوعي
حصل سابقا ولكن في ظل التوتر الذي نشهده
حاليا الى اين يمكن ان تصل هذه
المخاطر هل يمكن ان تحدث مواجهه حقيقيه
لقد شهدنا في الماضي ونتذكر عندما هناك
صاروخ هبط في بولندا
الجانبان ورسميا النيتو اسرعوا باللي
محاوله عزل هذا كذلك الحادث والتبريره ما
حصل واعتقد لحد الان ما شاهدناه هذا ما
حصل كان حادثا
وحصل كانت هناك اليات تجنب
التماس والاقتصادم
والجانبه ما ارادت تصعيد الموقف والنعم
صحيح ما حصل في هذه المره يساهم في خلق
مناخ
يمكن يؤدي الى المزيد والمزيد من التوتر
بين الاطراف المعنيه وهذا امر سيء خلال
النزاعات
شكرا لك سيد جامارك ريكلي رئيس قسم
المخاطر العالميه في مركز جنيف لسياسه
الامن
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد تصبحون على الف
خير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]